[Musik]
wir haben euch schon in einem früheren
Video hier auf visualpolitik gewarnt
Südkoreas neuer Präsident der
konservative Union social entwickelt
sich zu einem echten politischen
Erdbeben seit er die Präsidentschaft
übernommen hat vergeht keine Woche ohne
die Ankündigung einer weiteren wichtigen
Veränderung im Land durch die Regierung
und angesichts der allgemeinen
Erfolgsbilanz südkoreanischer
Präsidenten wenn es darum geht ihre
Versprechen einzuhalten müssen wir aber
natürlich genau beobachten was
letztendlich wirklich getan wird und was
nicht
[Musik]
immerhin haben in der Geschichte des
südkoreanischen Demokratie die
Präsidenten im Durchschnitt nur etwa 30%
ihrer Wahlversprechen erfüllt denn ja in
Südkorea führt man über diese Dinge
genau Buch der ehemalige Präsidenten
Mund zum Beispiel hielt nach vorläufigen
Daten nur 17% seiner Wahlversprechen da
haben gefühlt selbst
schießbodenpolitiker wie Karl Lauterbach
oder Boris Johnson eine bessere Bilanz
vorzuweisen aber natürlich wir sprechen
hier über Statistiken und die
funktionieren in einem so unscharfen
Metier wie der Politik nicht immer
außerdem haben ja auch nicht alle
Zusagen das gleiche Gewicht aber wie dem
auch sei die Tatsache dass Präsident
Jungen als quasi Quereinsteiger eben
nicht aus der professionellen
koreanischen Politik kommt könnte eine
gewisse Hoffnung in sich tragen dass
seine Statistik besser ausfallen wird im
Moment können wir nur eines sagen der
Mann sieht ganz so aus als hätte er dazu
den notwendigen Elan die Vision von
Südkorea die der neue Präsident zu
schaffen scheint unterscheidet sich von
der die das frühere Person hinterlassen
hat diametral alles sieht danach aus
dass Südkorea vor einem wahren
Neuaufbruch in eine strahlende Zukunft
steht also haben wir euch neugierig
gemacht seid ihr gespannt darauf zu
erfahren was die ersten Schritte sind
die jungen unternimmt um Südkorea
wiederzubeleben könnten sie die
Initialzündung sein für ein neues
Wirtschaftswunder könnten sie auch
andere Länder in der Region aber auch
weltweit inspirieren ist Südkorea gleich
zu tun und wie sieht der versprochene
Rechtsrock des Präsidenten eigentlich in
der Praxis aus in diesem Video werden
wir all diese Fragen beantworten lasst
uns also gleich loslegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine Lieben wissbegierigen
visualpolitik Zuschauer lasst uns doch
zu Beginn schnell die trockene aber für
das Verständnis Südkoreas notwendige
Theorie abhaken dann können wir uns
gleich auf die spannenden Themen stürzen
also Südkoreas politische System ist
präsidial so ähnlich wie in Frankreich
das heißt der Präsident ist nicht nur
ein machtloser Repräsentant sondern er
bestimmt die Richtlinien der
Regierungsgeschäfte sowie in Deutschland
der Kanzler eine der bemerkenswertesten
Eigenschaften dieses Systems ist jedoch
dass die parlaments- und
Präsidentschaftswahlen nicht auf das
gleiche Datum fallen und auch nicht so
nah aufeinanderfolgen wie zum Beispiel
in Frankreich die Konsequenz daraus ist
dass der Präsident des Landes
möglicherweise ohne eine Mehrheit im
Parlament regieren muss und das ist
genau das Szenario mit dem Jungs
konfrontiert wurde zwischen dem 10 Mai
2022 als er das Präsident man übernahm
und April 2024 bereits keine andere Wahl
haben als mit einem ihm gegenüber
oppositionell dominierten par zu
regieren
[Musik]
das bedeutet das den Präsidenten für
mindestens zwei der fünf Jahre seiner
Amtszeit die Hände gebunden sein könnten
wenn er nicht die Unterstützung der
Position in der Nationalversammlung
erhält er hat jedoch noch einen
Workarround zur Hand er kann sich dazu
entscheiden in dieser Zeit mehr oder
weniger per Präsident zu regieren was
genau das zu sein scheint was passieren
wird
[Musik]
eine Südkorea muss die Legislative
nämlich nicht jeden Erlass des
Präsidenten absegnen was den Präsidenten
weitreichende Befugnisse einräumt und es
ihnen im Grunde ermöglicht größere
Veränderungen vorzunehmen ohne dass ein
breiter Konsens erzielt werden muss und
obwohl diese Maßnahmen auf lange Sicht
leicht rückgängig gemacht werden können
sie erhebliche Auswirkungen auf das
politische wirtschaftliche und soziale
Leben des Landes haben die ersten
Vorschläge und Änderungen sind bereits
auf dem Tisch und sie haben es wahrlich
in sich also schauen wir Sie uns doch
mal an
[Musik]
mehr Markt und weniger Start
Biene bereits im letzten Video über den
Umschwung in Südkorea erwähnt haben ist
die unabsolut kein Fan von allem was
auch einen Anschein eines Haus linker
Politik zu haben scheint und zwar weder
gesellschaftlich noch ökonomisch
zumindest ist das seine eigene Aussage
und es ist der wirtschaftliche Bereich
in dem in den nächsten Jahren die
meisten Veränderungen zu erwarten sind
diese sind so wichtig und geht wichtig
dass ihr sie auf gar keinen Fall
verpassen dürft und wir hier auf
visualpolitik sind gerade zu
verpflichtet sie euch vorzustellen
zunächst einmal hat der neue Präsident
die zentralen Maßnahmen seines
fünfjahres Wirtschaftsplans bereits
veröffentlicht es handelt sich also
nicht um reine Versprechungen oder
Fantasien und Feste und klare Absichten
zu den Highlights zählen der radikale
Abbau bürokratischer Vorschriften für
die Wirtschaft und deutliche
Steuersenkungen
es wird eine drastische Verbesserung von
Vorschriften und Regelungen geben damit
diese nicht mehr die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der Unternehmen
untergraben und das Unternehmen tun
behindern die derzeitige wirtschaftliche
Lage innerhalb und außerhalb des Landes
ist sehr ernst in Zeiten der Krise
müssen wir Veränderungen vornehmen um
marktorientierter zu sein und den
Privatsektor die gesamte Wirtschaft
antreiben zu lassen Jürgen Präsident
Südkoreas die neue Regierung Südkoreas
sieht in der Krise also vor allem eine
Chance sie will ganz klar aus der Not
eine Punkt machen die derzeitige
weltweite Rezession bzw stadtration dazu
nutzen das ganze während der guten Jahre
angesammelte Fett loszuwerden und
gestärkt ja fitter denn je aus ihr her
zu gehen tatsächlich haben sie wohl
Finanzminister Schuh als auch andere
Minister in einer Erklärung sehr
deutlich gemacht dass der Kern des
Wirtschaftsplans der Regierung jung vor
allem die Deregulierung sein wird der
neue Wirtschaftsplan verpflichtet die
Regierung dazu staatliche Eingriffe in
den Markt zu minimieren und einen Wandel
des Wirtschaftsmodells hin zu einem
Modell zu fördern in dem der
Privatsektor und die Unternehmen die
dominierenden Akteure sind außerdem
sieht der Plan vor den Spitzensteuersatz
für Unternehmen von 25 auf 22% zu senken
aus dem Niveau von 2018 entspricht und
damit die von moonsche in eingeführten
Erhöhungen rückgängig macht außerdem
wird eine Überarbeitung des
Steuersystems vorgeschlagen um eine
Steuerbefreiung für Gewinne einzuführen
die nach Südkorea zurückgeführt werden
das Ziel ist es das Problem der
Doppelbesteuerung der Aktivitäten
südkoreanische Unternehmen im Ausland
ein für alle Mal zu lösen und das ist
noch nicht das Ende der feinstange denn
nun möchte nicht nur die bestehenden
Großkonzerne und jawoll entlasten
natürlich vor allem das in Südkorea mehr
neue Unternehmen und Frische und agile
Startups gegründet werden der
südkoreanische Innovationsmotor soll
nicht nur wieder angeworfen werden also
so viele PS bekommen wie nie zuvor
[Musik]
um dies zu erreichen schlägt ein
umfassendes und komplexes Programm für
Steuererleichterungen vor zum Beispiel
soll durch eine Ausweitung der
Steuerbefreiungen für Aktienoptionen als
eine von der mitarbeitervergütung
erreicht werden das Arbeitnehmer viel
stärker am Erfolg ihrer Unternehmen
teilhaben können als zuvor so soll auf
breiter Front auch bei Angestellten eine
langfristige Kultur von
Eigenverantwortung und Unternehmergeist
etabliert werden in den Köpfen der
Koreaner soll ein Umdenken stattfinden
sie alle sollen sich wie tatkräftiges
Stakeholder der eigenen Volkswirtschaft
fühlen und dann auch den persönlichen
Profit fühlen können die neue Regierung
will hierzu die Steuerbefreiung vom
derzeitigen Schwellenwert von 50
Millionen one auf 200 Millionen one
vervierfachen das sind über 150.000 Euro
mit anderen Worten wenn du für deine
Arbeit bis zum Betrag von 150.000 Euro
pro Jahr in Aktien entlohnt wirst musst
du dafür keine Steuern zahlen
damit hofft die Regierung das Start-ups
mehr hoch qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte
Gewinn wollen und ihnen einen großen
Teil ihres Gehalts in Aktien statt in
bar auszahlt dadurch gewinnen die
Unternehmen die Arbeitnehmer und auch
die Regierung denn die mistat-ups es
gibt desto mehr neue Märkte kann die
ganze Volkswirtschaft im In- und Ausland
erobern und entsprechend mehr
Wertschöpfung schaffen die sich dann
wieder in höheren Steuereinnahmen
auswirkt und vergesst nicht dass wir
hier noch immer über Südkorea sprechen
in diesem Land träumen die Menschen
davon in großen Konzernen zu arbeiten da
diese meist höhere Gehälter zahlen und
Arbeitsplatzsicherheit bieten
[Musik]
doch dadurch saugen die Großkonzerne zu
viele Talente vom Markt und untergraben
die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der kleinen
Unternehmen die doch viel agiler sind
und ein wesentlich höheres
Wachstumspotenzial aufweisen auf diese
Weise wird die Leistungsfähigkeit der
talentiertesten Kräfte jedoch eher dazu
genutzt die Macht der Großkonzerne zu
zementieren und eine Menge ihrer
Arbeitsleistung geht für bürokratische
Prozesse und Business politischen
Overhead drauf denn es liegt nun mal in
der Natur große Organisationen einen
höheren Anteil ihrer Mitarbeiter in
Bullshit Jobs ohne externe Wertschöpfung
zu binden als dies bei kleinen Firmen
der Fall ist welche gar nicht über die
dafür notwendigen historisch angehäuften
Puffer und Überschüsse verfügen dieses
Phänomen betrifft natürlich nicht nur
das Südkorea und wäre eigentlich ein
eigenes Video wert aber in Südkorea ist
dieses enorme Problem der Dualität in
diesem Bereich besonders stark
ausgeprägt wir sprechen hier quasi von
fast zwei unterschiedlichen
Volkswirtschaften und wir haben darüber
schon mehreren Videos über dieses
hochgradig interessante Land gesprochen
eine weitere der angekündigten Maßnahmen
ist die Änderung der Erbschaftssteuer
und passt auf denn das ist keine
Kleinigkeit diejenigen von euch die
visualpolitik schon eine Weile verfolgen
erinnern sich vielleicht noch in unser
Video über die Samsung und die damit
verbunden Probleme für die ganze
Wirtschaft und weiß nicht ich denke
diese Schlagzeilen sagen eine ganze
Menge darüber aus ein
erbschaftssteuerbescheid den du dir
nicht vorstellen kannst 10,8 Milliarden
Dollar die südkoreanische
samsung-familie wird außerdem Kunstwerke
im Wert von Milliarden von Dollar
Spenden darunter Picasso und Monet hohe
Erbschaftssteuern behindern das
Unternehmertum denn obwohl Südkorea eine
der geringsten Steuerbelastungen in der
OECD vorzuweisen hat kann es doch
andererseits sehr sehr teuer werden zu
sterben in Südkorea kostet einen das
wesentlich mehr als nur das Leben aber
Scherz beiseite eigentlich handelt es
sich vor allem mein Problem von reichen
Toten danach Angaben der koreanischen
Steuerbehörde mussten immer 2020 nur
2,9% der Erben diese Mehrzahl wenn es
jedoch einen ordentlichen Batzen zu
vererben gibt kann diese Steuer in
Südkorea bis zu 50% betragen und das
sogar zwischen Eltern und Kindern nach
einem progressiven Tarif mit Abzügen in
besten einkommensteuerstil versteht ihr
jetzt warum die Erben von liege und
hidden ehemaligen Präsidenten der
Samsung Group den größten
wirtschaftskundler des Landes mit einem
so gigantisch hohen Steuerbescheid
konfrontiert waren und auch wenn diese
Steuer vor allem Menschen betrifft die
sowieso viel Geld haben ob man sie nun
als gerecht empfindet oder nicht Fakt
ist dass ihre Auswirkungen auf die
gesamte Volkswirtschaft erheblich sein
können
[Musik]
da sich die großen Wirtschaftskonzerne
in Südkorea in Familienbesitz befinden
und folglich irgendwann vererbt werden
kann die Rechnung nach den Tod eines
Teilhabers so hoch ausfallen dass das
Unternehmen selbst finanziell schwer
getroffen wird denn oft müssen sich die
Erben hoch verschulden um die
Steuerschuld begleichen zu können sind
dazu gezwungen Unternehmens Ressourcen
als Sicherheiten zu verpfänden dadurch
sinkt unter anderem die Bonität der
Firma so das ist für sie schwieriger und
teurer wird Kredite aufzunehmen um zu
wachsen und zum Beispiel neue
Investitionen zu tätigen oder
Mitarbeiter einzustellen außerdem
treiben die hohen erbschaftsteuersätze
viele koreanische Unternehmer dazu ihr
Geld lieber aus dem Land herauszubringen
oder es gar komplett zu verlassen und im
Ausland Unternehmen zu gründen und ob es
einem nun gefällt oder nicht diese
Praxis will June nun ändern allerdings
scheint er selbst nicht genau zu wissen
wie er das eigentlich anstellen soll
[Musik]
an dieser Stelle ist also noch etwas
Skepsis angebracht neben der gerade
erwähnten Problematik geht es in uns
Plan aber auch um andere sehr wichtige
steuerliche Maßnahmen wie die
Abschaffung der Kapitalertragsteuer für
alle Investoren deren gewinnen 15.200
Euro pro Jahr nicht übersteigen im
Gegenzug sollen diejenigen die mehr als
7,5 Millionen Euro in Aktien halten mit
einer kleinen steuerbelegt werden
außerdem soll es möglich sein die
Zahlung der Schenkungssteuer
aufzuschieben wenn man eine
Familienmitglied Unternehmensteile
überschreibt und die
steuereinreißinfektionen in strategische
Technologien wie Halbleiter werden
verlängert auf diese Weise willionen die
Konkurrenzfähigkeit des südkoreanischen
Wirtschaft im globalen Maßstab boosten
und ihr somit helfen auf der sich
abzeichnen Weltwirtschaftskrise als
Sieger hervorzugehen okay jetzt werden
sich aber einige von euch fragen reicht
es denn dazu aus einfach ein wenig an
der Steuerschraube zu drehen war da
nicht von einer echten Revolution und
Kehrtwende die Rede ganz genau das beste
kommt nämlich noch Jungs ambitionier
vorzeigeplan mit dem es Südkorea wieder
in Schwung bringen will hat viel mehr zu
bieten und was genau verraten wir euch
jetzt
die 180 Grad Wende
[Musik]
nun weiß natürlich dass das Südkorea
nicht zu einem globalen Champion machen
kann indem er einfach nur vier
Steuersätze senkt und es dabei beläst
und tatsächlich könnte nichts weiter von
der Wahrheit entfernt sein der neue
Präsident will nämlich bei einigen der
umstrittensten und sensibelsten Themen
wieder Energiepolitik und den Renten
eine absolute Kehrtwende vollziehen denn
so wie es aussieht Schein nun eines
seiner großen Versprechen einen der
Kernpunkte seiner Wahlkampagne in die
Tat umzusetzen die fulminante
Renaissance der südkoreanischen
Kernenergie aus der sein vorgängermund
den Ausstieg eingeleitet hatte
tatsächlich hat sein Premierminister
bereits eine Vorschau auf den Plan
angekündigt mit denen das Ziel der
kohlenstoffneutralität bis 2050 erreicht
werden soll aber anstatt dieses Ziel mit
erneuerbaren Energien als Hauptquelle zu
erfüllen möchte er dass die Kernenergie
die Hauptrolle spielt und die
erneuerbaren Energien nur als Backup
dienen John fordert einen rationalen
Energie-Mix mit rational meint er vor
allem das Mumps früherer Plan zur
dekarbonisierung alles andere Preis
realistisch erscheint das Modell der
Vorgängerregierung kombinierte die
schrittweise Stilllegung von
Atomkraftwerken mit einem wilden
Engagement für erneuerbare Energien das
Problem ist dass dafür der Anteil der
erneuerbaren Energien 61-71 Prozent des
Energiemixes steigen müsste was die
meisten Experten aber für nicht machbar
halten
die damit verbundenen Konzepte zur
Netzregelung und Sicherstellung der
Versorgungssicherheit bezüglich der
Grund- und Spitzenlast waren zudem auch
vollkommen unrealistisch und hätten die
Konkurrenzfähigkeit des südkoreanischen
Wirtschaft massiv untergraben ein Risiko
welches gerade in einer herausziehenden
globalen Wirtschaftskrise reinen
Selbstmord darstellt deswegen hat die
neue Regierung die Reißleine gezogen und
ohne unnötig Zeit zu verplemmen
angekündigt dass sie den Bau der beiden
von der Vorgängerregierung nun
abgebrochenem Reaktoren wieder aufnehmen
und auch die Nutzungsdauer der
bestehenden Meiler mit sofortiger
Wirkung verlängern wird und das ist noch
nicht alles sie plant auch den Baum
mehrerer neuer Kernreaktoren um den
Anteil der Kernenergie an der
Stromerzeugung mittelfristig von 27,4
auf 34% zu erhöhen außerdem will sie
kleine modulare Reaktoren small modular
reactors Kurs smrs einführen deren
wichtige Rolle in der Zukunft der
Kernenergie sich bereits abzeichnet die
Regierung von den Einsatz erneuerbare
Energien jedoch weiterhin unterstützen
das ultimative Ziel ist es die
Stromerzeugung die Verbrennung fossile
Energieträger wie gaskohle und Öl die
derzeit 66% des südkoreanischen
Energiemixes ausmachen bis 2050 ganz
abzuschaffen und vollständig durch
erneuerbare Energiequellen und
Kernkraftwerke der vierten Generation zu
ersetzen denn letztere sind ein wahrer
gamechanger was die Sicherheit und
Umweltverträglichkeit der Kernenergie
angeht diese Reaktoren können den
radioaktiven Abfall älterer
Kernkraftwerke als Brennstoff nutzen und
den Isotope mit relativ kurzen Saft als
Zeiten umwandeln so dass eine sichere
und günstige Endlagerung keine Utopie
mehr darstellt mit den vorgestellten
Plänen wird es Südkorea zur weltweiten
Nummer eins der friedlichen Nutzung der
Atomenergie aufsteigen und das stellt
nicht nur im Inland eine nukleare
Revolution dar da immer mehr Länder auf
Kernkraft setzen könnten sich die
Koreaner ein derartigen
Kompetenzvorsprung erarbeiten dass ihre
Kerntechnik zum globalen Exportschlager
wird und der Wirtschaft einen
zusätzlichen außenhandelsboost mitsamt
der damit zusammenhängen diplomatischen
macht verschafft über das Thema Ja oder
Nein zur Kernenergie in Südkorea habe
übrigens ein eigenes Video gedreht noch
Region zum Präsident gewählt wurde und
schon damals haben wir vorausgesagt dass
sie ein Comeback erleben wird es ist
erfreulich zu sehen dass endlich auch
mal eine unserer positiven Prognosen
eingetroffen ist
das zweite große Wahlversprechen uns war
die Lösung des akuten wohnraummangels
vor allem in den Ballungsgebieten und
was meint ihr wie der neue Präsident
dieses Problem angehen möchte worauf
würdet ihr tippen mietpreisbremsen oder
gar Enteignungen um ja die letzten
Investoren und Bauträger abzuschrecken
nein Juns Lösungsansatz ist das genau
Gegenteil dessen was so geniale
Populisten wie zum Beispiel die in
Berlin aushecken sein Wirtschaftsplan
sieht doch tatsächlich vor die Steuern
für Vermieter zu senken damit diese mehr
in neue Wohnung investieren und die
Mieten senken können da auf dem
Mietmarkt weiterhin kurzfristige Risiken
bestehen versucht die Regierung durch
die Ausweitung von Steuer- und
finanzvergünstigungen und Erhöhung des
Angebots präventiv zu reagieren in
Südkorea ist übrigens ein sehr
eigentümliches mit und pachtsystem
namens giulose verbreitet anstatt
monatlich Miete zu zahlen hinterlegt der
Mieter eine riesige pauschale Kaution
die etwa 50 bis 80 Prozent des
Marktwerts Immobilien entspricht die
Eigentümer profitieren dann von der
Reinvestition der Kaution anstatt
unterschiedliche Mitte zu erhalten aber
das sei nur am Rande bemerkt die
Regierung hat nämlich auch versprochen
über die Schaffung von anreißen zu
Investitionen in den wohnmarkt direkt
Wohnraum zu schaffen ein Plan zum Bau
von 2,5 Millionen 9 Wohnungen im Land
soll bald vorliegen nun ja wir werden
sehen was daraus wirklich wird aber die
vielleicht heikels der Reform von allen
ist gerade die der Renten
[Musik]
Südkorea ist das Land mit der
schnellsten demografischen Alterung in
der OECD und das derzeitige Rentenmodell
das auf einem kapitalgedeckten System
über einen öffentlichen Renten
vorbasiert wird voraussichtlich bereits
in naher Zukunft nicht mehr in der Lage
sein die Zahlen neuer Rentner zu
bewältigen Präsident John hat klar
gesagt dass das aktuelle Modell seiner
Meinung nach eine Belastung für
zukünftige Generationen darstellt
deshalb will er unter anderem das
minimale Renteneintrittsalter von 60 auf
65 Jahre anheben oder es gab ganz
abschaffen Unternehmen sollen zu den
Vergünstigungen für die
Wiedereinstellung von Rentnern erhalten
was als aktiver Ruhestand bezeichnet
wird
und passt jetzt gut auf denn dieses
Thema ist alles andere als ein
kinkerlädchen es ist der soziale und
ökonomische Sprengstoff des
südkoreanischen Gesellschaft schlechthin
Angaben des südkoreanischen
Statistikamtes wird die Bevölkerung im
erwerbswegen Alter in den nächsten drei
Jahrzehnten um mehr als 35% schrumpfen
ein Phänomen dass die Produktion zu
senken droht während die öffentlichen
Ausgaben in die Höhe schießen könnten
nicht nur bei den Renten sondern auch
bei den Gesundheits- und
Sozialleistungen dieses Thema ist so
wichtig dass du jemanden eigenes Video
widmen werden also bitte Abo nicht
vergessen aber Moment mal wir sind noch
nicht am Ende dieses Videos ich habe
euch ja bereits gesagt dass der neue
Präsident mit sehr viel Elan an die
Sache herangehen die Reformen
öffentliche Einrichtungen ist eine
Aufgabe die nicht weiter aufgeschoben
werden darf die Evaluierung staatliche
Einrichtungen muss anhand strengster
Maßstäbe durchgeführt werden
Finanzmittel dürfen nur dort eingesetzt
werden wo sie wirklich gebraucht werden
und Sie müssen auf gütige und großzügige
Weise den wirklich sozial Schwachen
vorbehalten bleiben
welche die staatlich Unterstützung am
dringendsten benötigen wir reden hier
über nichts Geringeres als eine extrem
scharfe Fokussierung des
Wohlfahrtstaates auf die
allerschwächsten die sich wirklich nicht
mehr selbst helfen können alle anderen
werden mit anpacken müssen großzügige
Sozialleistungen nach dem gießkannten
Prinzip soll es nicht mehr geben können
was ich im Moment ebenfalls radikal
verändert hat ist die Außenpolitik sie
orientiert sich jetzt viel stärker an
den USA und Japan und schlägt gegenüber
China und Nordkorea sehr kritische fast
schon kriegerische Töne an dies bedeutet
dass die äquividistanz der vorherigen
monregierungen in wichtigen
außenpolitischen Fragen ganz klar
aufgegeben wurde und damit ist alles
gesagt Südkorea und Japan sind die
Bollwerke der Demokratie der
bevölkerungsreichsten und
wirtschaftsstärksten Regionen der Welt
Ostasiens das politische
gesellschaftliche und vor allem
wirtschaftliche Wettrennen indem sie
sich vor allem mit China befinden laufen
sie für die ganze freie Welt daher
müssen sich ganz besonders sputen und
sich keine Schnitzer keine ideologischen
Abenteuer und keine Liebhaberei mehr
erlauben sie lassen sich auf genau jene
siegerstrategien konzentrieren die Ihnen
die notwendigen Wettbewerbsvorteile
bringen mit denen sie den roten Riesen
in Schach halten können
beiden Union erwegen weitere
Militärübungen inmitten der Spannungen
mit Nordkorea
Südkoreas Ernährung an die USA richtet
sich laut Analysten gegen China während
den neue südkoreanische Regierung die
wirtschaftlichen und
sicherheitspolitischen Beziehungen des
Landes zu den USA vertieft warnen
Experten das Tools langjährige
Beziehungen zu China darunter leiden
könnten
wir müssten so schnell die möglich zu
den besten Tagen der japanisch
koreanischen Beziehungen zurückkehren
wenn wir das nicht erreichen halte ich
die weitere Zukunft eines freiheitlich
demokratischen Asiens für nicht
realistisch Jürgen Dokument neuer
südkoreanischer Botschafter in Japan
aber nach all dem was wir euch heute
erzählt haben glaubt ihr dass Juns
Maßnahmen wenn sie denn wirklich
umgesetzt werden Südkorea wirklich ein
neues Wirtschaftswunder bescheren
könnten glaubt ihr dass sie ausreichend
um die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit des Landes
im In- und Ausland wiederherzustellen
und was können ja müssen europäische
Länder von Südkorea lernen wie immer
sind auf eure angeregte Diskussion zu
diesen kontroversen Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat natürlich vielleicht
auch dass dabei gelernt habt was ja gibt
uns bitte einen like touch mit unseren
Freunden und vergesst nicht das Abo mit
Glöckchen um keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
mit uns dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
den PayPal Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video macht's gut
und bis bald